the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
and that brings us to today's lecture
which is also something I was not as
familiar with right so sort of a
disclaimer I might have gotten little
things wrong it might not be quite as
clear but do ask questions so if it's
stuff like lightning Network or discrete
log contracts well for me that's sort of
easy because I know it really well this
stuff is things I've known about but I
never really went as into the details so
it's a little bit like okay figure it
out enough well enough to explain it
rather than just well enough to sort of
understand how it works so the basic
idea is you want to hide the output
amounts so we saw last week how looking
at output amounts can be anonymized and
let you link a lot of different things
and so we'll look at how to do that how
do we hide out them when output amounts
and so we'll talk about commitments so
first we'll talk about the reasons why
and how to do it then we'll talk about
sort of the definition of commitments
like what is a commitment in
cryptography and then we'll talk about
Peterson commitments and then we'll talk
about range proofs and put it together
to get what's called confidential
transactions which is a sort of vaguely
non financial transactions it just means
the output amounts are secret okay
so yeah interrupt with any questions any
point of the way if something is not
clear
okay so coin joint last time we talked
about combining transactions with other
people where you have your input they
have their input if your output they
have their output and if you sort of
shuffle the ordering of the inputs and
outputs it might not be clear who's
sending what where right you're just
sort of aggregating it and in the
process you're losing information
because no one gets to see the sort of
border lines between hey this is one
transaction this is another transaction
it's all in the same transaction so you
can't really tell but one issue and a
really big issue was that the output
amounts can often reveal who's sending
what where so like in this example well
maybe I don't know who's a but who's B
who CUSD these all just look like
uniformly random addresses or pub keys
but if I see an input with ten coins and
input with two coins and an output with
two coins and output with ten coins
well there's probably something like
this going on right why why else would
you do this right if you were actually
trying to send two coins somewhere why
even involve this 10 coin input why not
just say two coins the two coins and
you're done so if it's if the goal is to
you know obscure the transaction graph
and make have better anonymity because
no one can tell which what's going where
well this doesn't really work I think
it's going like that and then I showed
that there is a way to do it whereas if
you have you know two to eight then the
eight is obviously from the person with
ten but the two different to coin
outputs are unlink able so that helps
but it's not not great
and then for things like the aggregate
signatures maybe you can get people to
aggregate their transactions together
because it's cheaper and smaller but in
general they'll have totally different
input sizes totally different output
sizes and it won't really give you any
anonymity and it won't give you any
privacy and it hurts fungibility so how
can we do this wouldn't it be great if
we could just hide the output amounts
that would be really cool so instead of
having it like this it's just you don't
see how many coins there are why don't
we just delete the output amounts
entirely why even it saves eight bytes
right so we can't we can't just delete
it right so what does this actually mean
this would this would be really cool
though right if we could just sort of
somehow obscure this so that no one can
tell what the amounts are and I guess
initially so they're sort of gonna be
some transition right since Bitcoin
wasn't built with this from the get-go
at some point there will be a
transaction where you can see the input
amounts but then you can't see the
output amounts but then you can sort of
have bounds and say well this neither of
these can be more than twelve right and
then as it goes forward and if the
transaction graph gets bigger those
bounds start getting really wide because
you're like well this might have been
like eleven and it's fine event one and
then the next transaction if it's mixed
in with a bunch of things that have a
pretty wide range you sort of have to
take the max
and then of all those things the min is
always gonna be like zero so it works
pretty well even with this trans session
oh you could also think of a new system
where you start with well you know
either you start with obscured amounts
or the first mining amounts or not
obscured and then you mix them anyway
so this seems like it'd be really useful
because it would allow you to combine
transactions and get better privacy also
just really nice in general right even
if you're not trying to combine with
anyone else it's really cool that people
can't see how much money you have if
people can see how many coins you have
they can try to charge you more they can
try to rob you there's all sorts of
reasons why people don't usually say how
much money they're carrying around right
or how much they make or how you know
things like that people are sort of
sensitive about pricing information and
some of its just sort of societal taboo
but also a lot of its like I don't want
people to know how much money I have and
I think there's like I read recently
like uber sort of doing this thing where
they they're like oh you're rich we're
gonna charge you more and people people
don't like that like it has been
historically doable like people you know
companies segment things but often the
way they do is they're like okay well
we're gonna make like you know
first-class seats and then economy seats
and the first-class seats don't take up
the space of ten economy seats they take
up the space of maybe two but they cost
like 10x and the idea is well if you're
rich we're gonna charge you more you can
have the fancy stuff and you know we're
gonna make more profit off of that
that's sort of more okay I guess but if
it's just know you're getting the same
economy seat but we know you're rich so
we're gonna charge you more that I don't
know yeah and we're sort of getting into
that future where there's enough data
that a lot of companies can do this and
some people probably myself included is
like wait no I don't like that I like
the way it was before where companies
didn't really know that much about me so
this is sort of an effort to try to keep
things obscure try to keep the customer
a bit more anonymous with respect to
merchants so that they don't have as
much information to sort of charge more
and then rob you it that's maybe more
Bitcoin specific where like
yeah I mean if you walk around in a you
know area that's sort of high crime with
a bunch of money hanging out of your
pocket that's a bad idea the Internet is
sort of a high crime area especially
with respect to Bitcoin and it's really
easy to see how much people have and so
like it's people you know you the
hackers know who to target especially if
it's like an exchange there they're
pretty clear okay this exchange has tons
money so it might not help the exchange
is that much it's sort of obvious they
have a lot of money but anyway okay so
this would be really cool to do I think
people sort of agree this would be
really cool right like this is this is a
nice thing to have
okay so yeah we can it also helps with
privacy right you're trying to make it
hard to link different outputs to each
other or link the outputs to a specific
person and hiding the amounts makes them
really hard to distinguish right so if
you don't know the amounts they become
sort of you completely uniform where
this is just a completely random address
I have no idea how many coins there are
like I have very little way to
distinguish between these of these
outputs I can sort of try to trace the
graph and say okay well this came from
here this came from here but they all
look the same so I've just got this big
graph with like no real information
other than the links between the notes
which is still information right but
it's much harder to tell what's going on
okay so we're sold how do we do it okay
first we need to define what are what
exactly are we're trying to do right
whoo what are we hiding from whom who
knows what when kind of thing so the
long-term state of the system no wooden
can see anything in it no no one can see
it in the mouse it's just okay a a sign
you know signature from key a signature
from key be some amount of coins you
don't see it you don't see any of this
okay so that's the long-term State but
wait people receiving the payments
should probably hum know how much
they're receiving right and they should
probably know how much they have if you
don't know how much money you're getting
that's not a very useful payment system
people sending should they should also
know how much money they're sending
right if the
can be completely determined by the
receiver that's also not a good payment
system I'm just gonna take lots of money
so we can have two views right we can
said okay only the sender and receiver
know the amounts how about that
we're from the network's point of view
so if I'm just the third party looking
at this transaction I don't see any of
the amounts I just see there's no I have
no idea how many coins are being sent
but from the sender's view the sender
says okay I know I have two coins here
seven coins I changed it from two
intended well anyway
two coins here seven coins here and I'm
sending seven coins here in two coins
there so the sender knows the whole
thing because they're the ones creating
this transaction and then maybe the
receiver maybe the receiver doesn't see
everything right maybe the sender can
prove to the receiver a single amount
but hide everything else that would be
ideal right so the the receiver only
sees oh i'm receiving two coins but i
actually don't know if i know this then
i can sort of figure out what these are
or at least the sum of them but if i
don't know any of these things i don't
know how much the person sending me
money has i just know oh i got two coins
cool that's what I wanted but I don't
learn anything about their inputs or
their other outputs within the
transaction so that would be ideal if we
can do that right so what we want is the
system where network doesn't see any of
the amounts the sender presumably sees
all of it now there could be cases where
there's multiple senders right and there
are two people working together to make
a transaction and maybe we don't see
each other's inputs but we'll keep it
simple for now where there's a single
sender and then the receiver only sees
their own output so that would be a
really powerful system then the receiver
would only know they're getting the
right amount and not learn anything else
about the sender's coins okay so yeah we
might want to like I'm saying you might
want to hide per output so if you have
it if it's just a sort of global like
either you see everything or you see you
know like you see nothing or you see
everything that's still pretty good
right that's still
than what we have when everyone sees
everything but it it is better if you
can hide it hide the rest of these three
things from the receiver so any ideas
some kind of encryption hide the amounts
of the only people with the right
private key can see the numbers right so
you encrypt I mean okay so actually I
don't think I've even talked about
encryption ever in this class because
there's no encryption in blockchain so
which is something you like if you read
something about blockchain and you like
blockchain is encrypted right now no
they don't know what I'm talking about
so I haven't actually defined encryption
but encryption is generally you have
some kind of private key you take a
clear text you apply you know you do
some so so like I had what signatures
you have so a set of functions so
encryption is just okay you've got some
encryption function which takes a key
and a message and outputs a ciphertext
and then you've got some kind of
decryption function which takes often in
the same key or something and then the
ciphertext and outputs the same message
this is symmetric encryption because
you're using the same key you can also
have a symmetric equipt encryption where
this could be a public key and this
could be a private key so in order to
decrypt you need the private key but in
order to encrypt you only need someone's
public key so in practice the all the
things that people in practice usually
stage it so you have an asymmetric
algorithm to agree on a key and then you
just use this symmetric encryption and
decryption where the keys are the same
because it's like way faster so you can
you can do this operation on the order
of like hundreds of megabytes a second
whereas the asymmetric ones are slow
they're sort of it's sort of like
signing in to it later but yeah it's
it's if you understand all the signing
and stuff it's actually not not too bad
but so maybe we could say okay well
there's some kind of private key that
the sender creates encrypts the amounts
and then they put the encrypted amounts
in the in the transact
and they reveal the key to the receiver
and potentially you could have different
keys for each amount right that would
work any problems with that idea you can
encrypt everything yeah yeah yeah okay
so that's that is a sort of no problem
it's a limit but that that limit will
carry forward to the stuff we actually
do so yeah you're gonna have to right
now in Bitcoin you can just sort of find
someone's address send them the coins
you're good with this system there will
be more interactivity between sender and
receiver so that's not great but not a
deal breaker right so yeah we will need
to do that other problem yeah the actual
solution gets it's kind of big so that's
that's not great either but the one that
really screws it up because they can't
see anything
well I can just do that right like well
how about I just make 70 coins and 2000
coin like I can just make as many coins
as I want no one can see anything
because the network just sees mmm
nothing
I have no idea how many coins are being
sent but I'm like hey I'm just making
more coins all over the place
and this this doesn't work right because
if I can just send coins to myself and
multiply them indefinitely and like it's
hidden so I'm like so to some extent
you're like well maybe the network
doesn't care right because well I'm
making them but they're only my own
coins but if the network doesn't see
anything it's easy to create the coins
and if those coins are later used I
can't tell if they were made up or not
so if I'm accepting so if I actually see
this right and someone's like hey here's
2000 coins I'm like dude this is you're
just making them up you can't just like
write extra zeros on a hundred dollar
bill like you
like this is come on no one's gonna no
one's gonna accept these later right
except I and and I won't even know
did you actually even have seven does
this seven coins come from something
where you did this same kind of thing
before so basically if we do that where
we completely obscure the amounts from
the network and from all third parties
then any time I'm going to accept this
I'm gonna have to enforce the rules
myself and then like retro actively
enforced the rules for all transactions
beforehand to make sure nothing like
this happened so we could do that we
could say okay it's all obscured the
third party the network doesn't see
anything and it's up to the participants
themselves to say well if you're gonna
send me coins since I know if I'm
sending it to someone later I'm gonna
have to provide some kind of proof that
this kind of nonsense didn't happen I'm
also gonna need proof that all of the
ancestor transactions that led to these
two and seven coins I'm gonna need those
amounts and so yeah you could maybe do
that right you could provide the
decryption keys for all previous amounts
but that basically gets you back to
where we are right now right not not
quite but pretty close
hey guys yeah either you allow people to
create coins or you basically are
revealing close to all previous amounts
eventually to everyone right because as
that transaction graph gets bigger and
bigger I'm gonna start having all these
like thousands and thousands of an
ancestor transactions that I'm gonna
have to require proof for you know I'm
gonna require all those decryption keys
to make sure nothing like this happened
and then eventually all the people
receiving money will be able to see
everything we're not quite everything
but a lot so it's like well third
parties you know the miners or maybe
people who are just looking at the
blockchain who aren't really receiving
any funds maybe it's it's hidden from
them but once you start actually using
the system you're gonna basically be
able to see everything so that's not
great and it would also be like really
annoying because then when you have to
like receive coins you have to like go
back through thousands of transactions
to make sure that didn't happen
so we need to prevent coin creation
while still keeping the amounts secret
this is a tricky problem right
any general ideas here yeah so wouldn't
it be cool if we could do this where you
sort of the network sees okay
there's W coins here there's X coins
here and there's Y coins here there's
equals here and then we have a proof W
plus X equals y plus C without telling
you what w XY and z are cool okay let's
do it
any ideas
so yeah this seems like this would be
this would work right this would this
would do it in that if we can reveal
like say hey the person I'm you know
person D Z is 2 okay cool
so I got two coins and they can also
verify that these amounts are correct
and then if you you could either keep
this proof only to the receiver but then
you'd have to give proofs to all the pre
about all the previous transactions or
you can just say no the whole network
enforces these proofs right this is now
a consensus rule where if you want you
know even if it's not your transaction
it might be a parent of your transaction
someday so you have to verify it if
you're gonna accept the block verify
these proofs for every transaction so
that would work yeah
yeah a minor or or yeah the miners would
do it and also the full notes you know
if you're running an ode well I'm not
receiving anything here but I just still
need to make sure this is a valid
transaction in order to accept it if the
miners receipt like miner is D and
receiving this coin then they'll they'll
know they they'll both get the proof
which is sort of redundant for them and
they'll also get the actual amount C
like so they'll know ok this is - yeah
so that miner would know more but that's
okay I guess other miners wouldn't where
others nodes wouldn't yeah if you're
participating
you'll potentially know more but the
idea is third parties just see a proof
and don't see the mounts okay so it's
already have no idea how many coins are
coming in on the inputs because they
don't have aut Exocet and the coin you
know so if you see an input you just see
okay it's pointing to some TX ID I don't
know how many coins there are I would
have to you could you know you could
provide a proof to an SP V wallet that
hey there were you know I can give you
that previous transaction and you can
see how many coins but then what about
the one before that so generally svv
wallets can't enforce that amounts are
correct or verify signatures because
they don't know enough about these
inputs whereas full nodes once you see
okay when you tell me input zero I know
how much I know what keys things like
that
yeah so svv can't well ya know there's
there's maybe some way to make the SBB
have it so that SBB proofs are
compatible with this but it's sort of
you already don't have that so I don't
think there's much idea you know there's
much much research into how to make this
SP be compatible but yeah that's a good
question okay other basic idea okay so
how do we do this so this will take a
little little like the actual way to do
this we'll take the rest of the class
because it's there's a lot of
it's like okay that seems like it'll
work it's like oh no it doesn't and this
is sort of replaying the ideas from
several years of people trying to do
this so how will we do this so there's
an idea called commitments and the
simplest form of commitment is you
commit to some value you output it call
it see and then you reveal the value and
then someone can verify okay well given
C and the value you just revealed did
what is that a correct commitment right
so I say okay I'm committing to the
value too
I'm outputting something C and then
revealing oh it was - I was like okay
let me throw this into my function - and
C does that does those match oh it's
true okay we're good
and then there's certain properties
you'd want like you don't want people
that well okay well I think I have
slides about that so a hash function is
a commitment right I can say the hash of
5 is 6 8 ft whatever and then I commit
to 6 8 something I publish this I tell
everyone
ok I'm committing to something I'm not
gonna tell you what I'm committing to
exactly but here's this 6 8 ft 0 b7
someone hash output and then I reveal
you know days later hey my my the thing
I was committing to that was 5 and then
everyone can check well let me throw 5
into my hash function it was this ok
true so that's a commitment scheme right
it is binding so there's like binding
and hiding and there's different
properties of commitment schemes so this
we could say is a binding
computationally binding commitments game
and that I'm not gonna be able to once
I've committed to this I'm not gonna be
able to find another number so I'm not
gonna be able to say oh actually it was
6 and then get the same commitment now
right so I'm not gonna so in practice
this is really long right this is like a
shot to output I didn't want to write
the whole thing but it like goes to here
or two lines so the idea is I can't find
another number
especially another exactly the number I
want but I can't find any other number
that will get me to that same house a
hash output right that's a collision and
I'm gonna have to try it well wait so
for a specific number I'd have to try to
do the 256 for any collision I only have
to do to the 128 but still both of those
are really big numbers I can't do it so
it's computationally binding right if I
had some amazing computer that could you
know perform infinite calculation I
could actually find a collision so
there's there's the distinction between
like computationally and information
theoretically information theoretically
is like stronger where even if I had
like the most powerful computer I still
couldn't do this where as binding in
this case it's computationally binding
computationally is good enough
everything in Bitcoin is already
everything in all these systems is
already basically computationally there
are some schemes which are not
computationally bound so one of the
parts here and like the Petersons
commitments are not actually
computationally and things like severe
secret sharing and a couple other things
where it's like hey this is not
dependent on processing power even if
you have infinite processing power you
just can't figure out what the values
are which is you know cooler but it's
nice to have it's not a requirement for
our systems okay so this is binding any
ideas of what this is not why this is
would not be a good commitment scheme
you want to commit to a value and then
later reveal it you don't want the
person who's committing to be able to
change their commitment what else might
you want but this probably doesn't
provide
yeah okay so you want to be able to do
fancy stuff the commitments before we
even get there that's in like five or
six slides before we get there this
doesn't satisfy something else we want
so if I'm committing to a number I'm
just like okay I'm gonna commit to the
number of pizzas I'm ordering at my
party and everyone's like wondering like
how many pieces you gonna order well I
just kind of try things right it's
binding but it's not hiding so oops
verifier can easily guess and check the
committed value right so okay for I
equals zero just keep trying different
eyes and see if the hash matches six 8ft
you and this will take very little time
because five is gonna happen pretty
quick and then everyone will know okay
he's ordering five pizzas sounds like a
decent party but not really worth going
out of my way to go to if it was ffffff
pizzas that would be something else
okay so solution pretty pretty
straightforward solution add a blinding
factor so we're gonna call that our I
guess our is random yeah so let's say
okay our is be a PC seven five seven
nine and now I'm gonna take the hash of
five and concatenate our and say okay
now this is a different hash and now to
reveal Mike you know reveal what I was
committing to you reveal both v and r
and then sort of you need you know you
need to tell people what order you're
doing things in you need the system
needs to be predefined right you can't
sort of when you're committing you also
have to sort of commit to the algorithms
or have pre agreed-upon algorithms
because otherwise yeah you could do
something like no I committed to r5 was
my blinding factor you know so you need
you need to have sort of protocols set
up beforehand which you never know that
could be some you know if you just say
hey I'm committing here's this value
you're like okay well how are you
committing what hash fun
what you know what are you doing but
that's sort of I don't know obvious it
might not be super obvious so you have
to be careful mother okay so this is now
blinding and you know it's it's hidden
and it's it's still binding right you
can't change it to like six I think
that's the next lightweight okay yeah so
you can't change this to six and change
to a different are I mean you could but
you'd have to do you still have to do a
lot of computation and this is now
actually some things get easier right so
before if you really wanted to reveal
that it was six basically can write
because there's a single output for six
and it just doesn't match this so
there's not like if you if you have a
single chosen value that you want to
reveal that's not the one that you
committed to you're basically stuck
there's no way to get around it even
computationally with this that's not
true right it's like I really want to
reveal six well I can come up with a
different R such that the hash of six
and our prime is that and then that's
now computational slight distinction
right it's it's still it's still binding
computationally but before chosen values
may not have been yeah so that's I guess
the difference right it's it's
computationally binding for any value
but for a specific value it might be
sort of in from not information
theoretic but you just can't do it
because they're the hash function
doesn't help you there okay so what else
do we want to do oh you're saying we
need more we want to be able to prove
things about the commitments so we need
some kind of homomorphic commitments and
we've seen the homomorphic properties of
these elliptic curve points which are
really nice right where you can add
private keys or add scalars and that's
the same as adding these points on a
curve so let's try that we want
something like this we want a commit to
X commit to Y and get these commitments
a and B and then we were on to reveal Z
which is X plus y
and then we want the verify function
that's put Z in and a and B either a
plus B or a and B separately and return
true right so we don't want to reveal x
and y separately we will reveal the sum
of x plus y and then we will reveal you
know and then we'll just have the
commitments themselves so you know if
since these are the same operator it be
cool if that worked this is what we want
right and ok so that's actually not that
bad but we also want all those
properties where it's hiding and it's
binding and things like that so what
should we try first idea is yeah ok this
would be useful how can we build this we
want to you know we can reveal sums
without revealing individual parts that
we've committed to so probably the first
idea is let's just use private keys and
public keys right let's use you know a
times G and that kind of thing oh and I
forgot the joke G how can we build this
G G so yeah you want a commitment to X
you want to commitment to why you want
to reveal Z as X plus y so what if you
did this you said okay I'm gonna make a
point on the curve X which is just my
value x times G point on the curve Y
which is my value y times G this does
have that homomorphic property right but
is this binding okay it is yeah well
yeah I can't come up with a different X
that gets me to that point right so so
multiplying by the generator point is
sort of like a hash function in that
you're not gonna be able to find
collisions right so you can't find two
different private keys that give you the
same public key sometimes you can so I
don't like in this specific case this
binding there's a bunch of asterisks is
there I probably shouldn't yeah it gets
complicated there are some curves where
it's not and some systems where it's not
and there have been problems and
currencies where people assume that this
is the case I think in Manero but yeah
the curves the curve for Bitcoin I think
it's Y Q no y squared equals x cubed
plus or minus minus seven I think that's
it it looks sort of like this it's
symmetric which that isn't I think I had
it in like an earlier one and then the
x-axis is like like this is the origin
ish and then the idea is you know you
have points and you can so the sum is
you know if you have well the sum
there's gonna be like here except it's
like here the idea is three any any line
you draw more or less will intersect at
three points unless it intersects at a
tangent or if it's straight up then you
say it intersects at the point at
infinity right so but any you know any
random line you make will probably
intersect in three different points and
so then you can say okay well if this is
a B and C we define a plus B plus C to
be zero so then we would define B plus C
to be here negative a and the negation
is you just flip it over the x-axis so
yeah there there I talked about this a
little bit before but the idea is you've
still got this nice property where you
pick a point on here G just everyone
picks a random point and it's a
generator because if you keep adding so
if you say okay here's G sorry I take
the tangent fine this is to G take the
tangent here
maybe goes here to 3G take the tangent
here or no that would be 4G sorry this
will be H II so you can keep adding the
G and you'll eventually cover the entire
curve so and get back to G so that's why
it's sort of a generator because it like
lets you get to every point by just
multiplying so the nice property here is
if you have some regular x times G and
some number y times G you can also do X
plus y times G and that equals x g plus
y g right so you can add the points and
that's the same as adding the scalars
before you multiply by G and that's what
basically we use for everything and then
the idea is you can't go back right
given a point let's say we call this big
X give it a point big X which is little
X times G you can't figure out what X is
so you can't divide by a point right you
can't say Oh given X I want to do X
divided by G which is little X
I can't divide so I'm stuck right I can
multiply by just repeatedly adding what
division is not defined okay so this is
binding but I don't want it there's
asterisks is there but it's not blinded
right so the same problem is just the
the raw hash based commitment where if I
want to commit to the number five and I
just say okay five times G and that's my
point that I'm gonna use for my
commitment you know same same problem
for loop will pretty quickly show you
that was five okay how about this seems
like a good idea I should say unless
obviously it's not a good idea way
so why don't we say okay put a add a
blinding factor
what would this what would the problem
be here I'm saying okay I'm gonna you
know I want to commit to five I'm gonna
add some random number R and then
multiply that that sum by G and then
when I want to reveal that my I was
committed to five I reveal a five in are
no but I can say look the first well
yeah you get the problem is addition is
easy to break right I can just say well
when I committed to five plus R it
revealed 5 and R but it's not binding
right I can just find our prime which is
5 plus R minus 6 and then 6 plus that R
prime is gonna be 6 plus 5 plus or minus
6 you know like I can just compute
whatever our prime I want and whatever
number I want to reveal later so this is
a binding anymore right I'm now adding a
random thing in and I'm committing to
the sum of the thing I want and a random
thing but it's not binding because that
addition I can I can play with so how
about this I'll hash five and
concatenate R and then multiply that
hashed output by G maybe but then it's
no longer homomorphic right then I can't
add so if I have you know like the hash
of 5 and R 1 times G and then the hash
of 7 and r2 times G I can't add these
anymore and then have the the fives and
sevens add up to 12 or it won't work
because now it's a hash and I've just
got these hashes adding and you don't
really get any meaning there so that
doesn't work either so we're stuck yeah
then the way you actually do it is
totally non obvious and introducing G's
for eternal twin H
you make another point on the curve and
you just call it H which is the letter
after G yeah it's another generator
point distinct from G so you just pick
one you say okay here's here's H you
also need to make sure that nobody knows
n such that M times G equals H that n
might exist but you want to be sure that
no one knows what it is
because if you know how to sort of move
between G and H then that'll break this
um but if you take two random points you
know G was sort of randomly chosen and
you chose a random H this shouldn't be
possible right that would be breaking
the discrete log problem so I shouldn't
be able to compute okay well what is H
divided by G well you shouldn't be able
to compute that and so I think in a lot
of cases they'll define H as like take
the hash of G's x-coordinate and then
assign that to the x-coordinate for H
something like that so it looks pretty
random should be able to find it okay so
we've got another another arbitrary
point on the curve that we're gonna
start use using for multiplying things
okay and so this is basically a Peterson
commitment which sounds involved and it
gets involved but really it's not it on
it's you know at its core it's not too
bad it's saying we're gonna have a
blinding factor and the actual value
we're committing to and so now I'm
multiplying the blinding factor by G and
the actual value by H and I'm just
adding those two up right so you know
how we can do that we can just say okay
if if my actual value is 5 I take five H
by taking the tangent getting to H
taking the tangent again getting for H
and then adding for H and H by drawing a
line between them I'll get five H and
then I'll also get our R's gonna be some
giant random thing right ours not gonna
be like five ours gonna be like a
256-bit random number and that will
obscure what H was what sorry what V was
because I add them together so this is
by
unless I know the ratio right unless I
know H over G or or G or H whatever same
thing or I can't come up with another R
and V pair that gets me back to X so I
can try like there there are there is
one right there's all I there's probably
bazillions of well if I could find a
different R I could then reveal that V
was 8 instead of 7 but I can't find that
art because I need to know some way to
get between G and H like some factor n
where n times G equals H if I don't know
that I can't do this I'm you know it is
binding it's also hiding right so you
might successfully guess I might commit
V equals 5 do some random number R times
G Plus 5 H and you might guess correctly
but oh this should have been G oops
sorry this is G but if I have some
really long random number times G it's
also in X and you're not gonna be able
to guess that so this is also hiding and
it's homomorphic so what we can do is we
can say okay
X is R 1 G Plus v1 h y is r 2 G Plus V 2
H and what if I want to prove that Z is
value 1 plus value 2 without revealing
them individually can you see how I
could do that well I can reveal I can
actually reveal both R's individually
well no sorry I cannot reveal both R's
individually because then you might be
able to yeah you'd be able to figure out
the values but I can reveal the sum of
the ARS and the sum of the meats right
so I can say okay well I'm gonna define
a point Z which is point X plus point y
and that's just going to be the sum of
the R values those some of those random
values times G plus the sum of the
actual values I've committed 2 times H
and then I reveal just the sums right
this I reveal that and then the verifier
can do the math themselves and say okay
well is this are they don't so it's a
little hard I'm revealing R and V which
is equal to this but I'm not revealing
these separately right I only reveal the
songs and then the verifier can check
okay is this are they gave times J plus
this V they gave times H equal to these
two points added together and if it is
they've sort of proven okay the song so
for example yeah it's finding hiding and
home morphic so this would allow us to
make proofs right yeah Oh more pick you
revealed of some of the R's you reveal
the some of the V's works so basically
now instead of coin amounts which are
like eight byte you entered there in 64
s I just provide elliptic curve points
which are 33 bytes so it's you know a
bit bigger not a huge deal I can put
another you know 20-something bytes in
my outputs no big deal
and then I just provide a proof by
revealing these sums each time right so
I prove that W plus X equals y plus C
and everyone can see okay this actually
little W amount of coins there's
actually Y coins there's actually X
coins there's actually Z coins and
there's a blinding factor that all the
participants have to keep track of so
the receivers view is they learn their
own V and R right so the receiver when
when someone sends they would have to
tell the receiver hey here's our for the
sender makes up our for and they can
just compute let's you know make a
random R 3 and then compute R 4 such
that our
or plus r3 equals r1 plus r2 right they
need to make sure that the randomness is
add up which is easy because they're
just regular scalars and the the sender
has full control over r3 and r4 so
basically make random ones until you get
to the last one and then make the last
one such that they all add up to the
right number and then the sender can say
okay well here's your r4 and here's to
you know you're getting two coins and
the receiver gets those two numbers and
says okay cool
I can see that this transaction commits
to Z a point and you gave me an R and a
V that that you know when I do the
operation I get Z so I know that you
successfully you know you've revealed
that these are actually two coins and I
can use these values later when I want
to send my own coins so this works but
there's more problems any idea what the
next big problem is I mean there's sort
of no way around that right if there's
only one input or wait well only and the
receiver learnt so if the receiver
learns these they will be able to this
thing
if you know the total amount of inputs
and there's only one other you can just
subtract and figure it out right so
there's there's all sorts of things if
there's only one output that person
knows it's the sum of all the inputs
right in this case you don't you don't
have to they don't have to reveal to you
the V they just have to reveal that two
plus y equals W plus X so you don't have
to you don't have to learn their input
amounts yeah if there's only one output
then you learn like okay well if this is
to these must have added up to two but I
don't learn it exactly which so this is
useful there's still a big problem yeah
okay sorry for you can prove W plus X
equals y plus Z it works it's great
nodes only just need nodes can just
compute these numbers and they're good
right so so one thing you could do here
okay wait so so there's one thing that
you could do to break it but it's
actually not a big deal and then there's
another thing you can do to break it
it's a really big deal yeah
kind of well your yeah but how exactly
so one thing you could do is I think I
said so so basically you can verify it
and put in the outputs add up all the
points make sure they're equal you
reveal our D to the person receiving and
you don't want to forget our if you are
a sort of now a private key
if you forget our you're stuck you can't
prove anything anymore you can make
invalid output which are just points
with no known R and V but nobody should
accept those right so you can just do
this where I have no idea what's like
there is no commitment here maybe these
have valid commitments but this is just
a point which is w plus X minus y and
there's no known our values or Z or or V
values for these things and from the
network's point of view this will still
be valid right the networks are saying
well W plus x equals y plus Z we're good
but then anyone accepting that
transaction you're not going to be able
to give them in our value and so they're
not going to say this is actual money so
this is possible but it's not a huge
problem because well you can destroy
your own money you can already do that
in a million different ways in Bitcoin
but yeah if you send to it to an output
amount that doesn't have an actual R and
V value no that doesn't have a valid
Petersons commitment those coins can
essentially be destroyed because no
one's gonna be able to figure out ours
and stuff for here so that's that's one
issue not a big issue right it's just
don't do that right don't don't ruin
your own money make sure you always have
valid commitments and when you're
accepting payments always make sure that
you're given the you know the values in
the random the random blinding factors
so that's one little risk but not the
big problem
anyone have idea about the big problem
so as a hint all of these things and I
haven't written it because it gets
really redundant all of these things are
like mod P right which is some giant
prime number that's like
- to the 256 - 17 or not it's it's not
in some in the curvy d25 509 it's 2 to
the 2 5 5 - 19
so that's like an easy one to remember
so that's why they call it curve - 5 5 1
9 in Bitcoin it's 2 to the 256 - some
numbers that are like not too huge so
since all of these things are modulo
some big prime number what's the
potential problem here it's a big
problem or in some ways the opposite of
a big problem not a small problem the
opposite of a big problem but not small
being negative problem you can basically
commit to negative values right so I
just said negative 99 coins here
positive 108 points here the numbers all
work out so you don't actually have
negative usually if you're doing like
mod mod some integer you don't think of
it as negative but you can think of
being almost right at the top of that
modulo range as being equivalent to
being you know negative 1 so if you say
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna have P minus 1
well that's some huge number that's
within the you know allowable range but
it also will let you treat it as a
negative 1 for operations like addition
and multiplication so this would work
and you can you can calculate what
negative 99 is that's just gonna be you
know P minus 99 or minus 100 I always am
off by 1 when I do these things anyway
so so you can calculate okay it's not
really minus 99 right it's some big
number that's gonna be 32 bytes long
that's modulo you know modulo P it
doesn't change but it's equivalent to
minus 99 so that if I do add these to
the skew
Plus this other small number it sort of
loops over that modulo and then gets
back to what nine right so this Plus
this is gonna be nine even though this
is some you know really long number this
Plus this is gonna be nine and then it
all adds up and then I've got this
either negative or implausibly large
value that I've committed to but I can
just ignore that right I can get rid of
that yeah I'm negative output will be
hidden right no one will see that I've
got this negative 99 here and then I can
just toss it and end up with a whole
bunch of negative values that are like
anti coins and a whole bunch of more new
coins and later on I can prove I've got
valid proofs all these you know w plus x
equals y plus z proofs worked the whole
time shoot so we're kind of stuck we
need more than a proof that the sums are
equal it was working really well but
just a proof that the sums are equal is
not enough because we're we're modulo
this big prime number and so you can
sort of make these negations we also
need a proof that they're non-negative
and not just not negative right because
that that negative 99 is actually
essentially you know P minus 99 which is
some huge it's like 2 to the 256 - 99
ish so it's not just that the non
negative we have to prove that they're
reasonably sized but they're fairly
small so if you could prove okay this
number is non-negative and it's less
than 2 to the 64 that would be cool how
can we prove something about the number
itself without revealing it so now this
is an even trickier problem because
before we wanted to prove a sum right we
wanted to prove that ok z equals x plus
y but i don't want to tell you what X
plus y is but I'll tell you what sees
that was reprove proving a relation
between these numbers this is just
proving something about that number
itself individually right we have to
prove
individual numbers ranges so we have to
say okay this 2h there's a 2h in there I
don't I can't show you it because I'm
just committing 2w but I want to somehow
show you that the the the V here which
happens to be two but I can tell you the
V there is within a small range without
telling you what it is without revealing
it tricky okay so so what you can try to
do is sign with the points somehow this
is what'll get us there
the idea of okay well we've got these
Peterson commitments we've got these
points on a curve those are sort of
public keys or that's how we used to
usually think of them can we like sign
we know the private keys we know r1 we
know - can we make signature somehow and
like somehow use that to reveal some
information about H but not too much so
the signature equation s you know they
didn't really review it as much but
we've talked about this a couple times
come up with a random value k take the
hash of K times G and the message to be
signed times your private key that's
your signature s the problem is X Y or
your value that you've got committed to
here it's r 2g plus a 7h what's your
private key here what's our two plus
seven but no because you know the
private scalars here but there's two
points involved in this key so you can't
make a signature you generally
signatures are with respect to a single
generator point right the way to verify
this is multiply both sides by G right s
times G should be K times G minus the
hash occasion of G message times a times
G which is a public key that works but
now you've got H in here so we're stuck
we could try to define another signature
thing with like both a Sanji but that
doesn't work but what we can show it's
kind of interesting well what if V is
then X is are two times G Plus zero H
which is just are 2 times G right like
this is this is nothing there's no H
here and that means my private key is
just gonna be our two well now I can
sign now I can resign with respect to G
with this point X that I've committed to
because the value is zero right the
value the thing that I'm multiplying by
H is zero so I don't so it'll work for a
signature system like the same regular
old signature equation that we use I can
sign a message with key big X and so
this is a proof of a zero value I'll
just sign with my own key so if X is you
know some random some random binding
factor times G plus zero times H where V
the V the value are committing to is
zero well that means that the signature
is just and what do you so the question
is what message do you sign well maybe
sign the message which is the pump key
itself you sort of don't need to sign a
message but throw that in there and then
this will work right and someone can say
hey here's a signature from key X and
the signatures arbitrary can be a
signature of any message you want but
the fact that they are able to produce a
signature reveals to you that V is 0 so
that's kind of cool
it's actually not that cool right
because well I just revealed my value
and it revealed to be 0 but I did it
without revealing R so that is kind of
cool right I could do it by just saying
hey here's my R and V values multiply
them and add them up to see that it gets
to the point I committed to but I can
now prove that I can prove something
about V without revealing anything about
R right before we were saying the way
you reveal these commitments is you
reveal the blinding factor and you
reveal the value itself well now I can
keep the blinding factor secret and
reveal a little bit of information about
V
this works and you can't sign if H is
nonzero right you're not gonna be able
to you know you're not going to be able
to calculate any valid signature unless
V is V so you can also do this with a
proof of V equals 1 again sign your own
key so you define X prime to be just X
minus H and then you can say well look
I'm gonna prove to you that I'm gonna
prove to you that V is 1 and the way I
do that is take the point I've committed
to X subtract H from it and I'll provide
a signature on that new point and I
can't do that unless V is 1 right so if
I have this and then I subtract H then I
get back to our times G I can now
provide a signature of just using R
it'll work so what does this get us we
can prove that V is 0 or it can prove
that V is 1 or really we can prove that
V is anything just subtract a whole
bunch of H's right say hey subtract
7,000 H and now I'll provide a signature
and that proves that V was 7,000 but
wait we just revealed V so what's the
point right did that really get us
anywhere if if we can make a signature
that reveals the value we've committed
to with hiding the rest of the stuff
it's that useful right like if it's kind
of cool but what can we do with this any
ideas ok so there's another part that I
yeah what didn't have time to introduce
but maybe we'll at some point and you
can read about it it's really cool ring
signatures a ring signature is similar
to a normal signature you've got you
know key pairs
you've got sign verify but there's a set
of public keys during the signing and
verification process so the basic idea
is I sign a message with one of the
public keys
but I don't tell you which one and you
verify that yep there was a signature
here I'm not quite sure who signed it
there's possibly three or four different
people who may have signed it but I know
one of them signed it but not which so
basically it's the the key generation
step same as before right
you have some kind of key Jen takes in
some randomness and it spits out a
private key and a public key for you you
can use those later sign on the other
hand sign function used to just have the
message to sign in your private key and
would output a signature in ring
signatures you sign with the message you
want to sign your private key and then
pick a list of other people's public
keys and this list can be you know just
a single one it can be a thousand you
pick a bunch of other people's public
keys and you generate a signature and
then verify you use the signature to it
you know you take the signature in the
message that's been signed and that list
of pub keys and it outputs a boolean of
yep that signature worked or no it
didn't but it doesn't tell you which of
the public keys signed so this is a
really cool idea I think the initial
paper was how to leak a secret which was
and then there's different papers about
different more efficient rigged
signatures but this is a really cool
thing to have to use I think this could
be really cool for a lot of different
things if people actually had public
keys that they were associated with and
like wrote them on their business cards
and stuff like I do you could then have
like you know leaking information that's
more credible so instead of just the
newspaper saying you know sources close
to the matter said X Y Z or you know a
top official at the White House said
this you could actually have it being
signed and it's like okay well we've got
all these different White House
officials public keys one of them signed
this message so either there was a key
compromised and they all lost their keys
which is in practice probably more
likely in that case or one of these
people actually find this message and I
know it's one of them but it doesn't
reveal anything about
of the public keys that's pretty cool
okay so you can verify from it's from a
key in the array of public keys but not
which so let's put these together I can
sign with X to prove that V is zero I
could also sign with X prime which I'm
defining is X minus H to prove that V is
one well what if I have a ring signature
where I say I'm gonna produce a
signature from both of these pumps you
know from one of these two public keys
and that would prove that V is either 0
or 1 but it doesn't prove which right
makes sense so the idea is I can make
these signatures that essentially reveal
what V is right they they indirectly
reveal what V is by saying there's no
way I could have made this signature
unless V was zero or unless V was one
because you're you know you're you know
that the H component right V is the
coefficient for H so you need to know
that I don't have an H component in
there if I'm gonna make a signature with
respect to G and I can make any number
of you know I can I can make any number
of different sort of X Prime's by
subtracting different amounts of H but a
single signature would just reveal what
V was which isn't useful but a ring
signature whereas I can say okay well
there's two different pump keys right
one of those X one of them's X Prime you
subtract H and I'm gonna provide a ring
signature from one of these to pub keys
now I've proven to you okay well V is
either 0 or 1 I can't offer you can't be
both any but it can't be - it can't be 3
it's got to be one of those two values
so does this make sense
questions on this yes
oh well the original scheme it's kind of
complicated that the one used in
confidential transactions is boramy n'
ring signatures yeah it's it's you do a
bunch of like hash functions that like I
can't I don't know it I don't even
really know it well enough myself to
really be able to explain it in like a
minute but basically you compute
something on all of the pomp keys and
then verify the signature on like the
aggregate pub key kind of is a way to
think about it the signatures can that
the computing time gets big with with
the number of pub keys right so if you
have like millions of fum keys that
could possibly be signing this is the
verification algorithm gets really
time-consuming so yeah so yeah I can
maybe go into rigged signatures another
time but yeah
well you know these are good so we've
just proven that we've done quite a bit
more than the proof it's not negative
we've proved that it's exactly zero or
exactly one yeah we might want more
values so make a rigged signature from a
million different public keys where the
table n is just pumping when is one when
it's H right and then I just prove that
V is somewhere in the range from zero to
no no no no no no it goes up the best is
linear or no there might be sorry
there's probably sublinear now but yeah
this is not feasible this would that the
traditional ring signatures are linear
with the number of public keys to be
verified so if you did this
yeah well all even then you'd have to
you'd have to sort of throw though
because you have to at least throw the
public key into the verification
function right and so that means you
need to compute a million pub keys throw
it into that function it's gonna take a
long time so this is not itself gonna
work right did you yes Manero uses
rigged signatures for for a different
reason
well now they use it for this kind of
thing too the Monaro ring signature was
initially used for not hiding the
amounts but hiding which outputs were
being spent so in Bitcoin you have you
know everyone should sew in Bitcoin
so in Bitcoin if you have a transaction
you say okay here's my input here's my
output and the simplest one it's just
like okay this points to you know TX
five or something and my output is
address maybe you know address its
address B and it's got seven coins
everyone can see what you're spending
the idea in one arrow is I don't point
to an input I just provide a signature
and it's up to you to figure out where
that signatures like so I provide a
signature and a list of pub keys pub a
pub B so the smallest would be two and
then I'd you know provide a key you know
so the idea is instead of thinking of it
as outputs you just sort of think as pub
keys have associated values so you don't
look at the transactions themselves say
okay this is key C and there previously
have been pub key a and pub key B have
had values you know seven coins sent to
them and I can now say look I'm gonna
provide a ring signature from either
pokey a or pub key be and I'm not gonna
tell you which but you can see that both
pub key a and pub TB have received seven
coins in the past I want to send seven
coins over here I'm gonna prove that I
own one of those two and then you can
validate that the transactions valid and
then if later you see another
transaction with a ring signature from
pub a but B also sending you know two
key d7 coins okay now I can believe pub
infamy right I don't know which this you
know so in transaction one I don't know
whether a or b a was spent but one of
those two was and then transaction - I
don't know whether a or beers went one
of them was but anyway they both went
spent now and so I can you know delete
them from my storage but the ring
signatures in one era were to use to
obscure the transaction graph itself
where you can see that there's a bunch
of different keys that have you know
money associated with them and I'm gonna
provide a signature that I own one of
them but I don't tell you which and now
they also do confidential transactions
to obscure the outputs using rigged
signatures as well so yeah I don't
what are is interesting I I haven't
looked at it as that closely so I know
that's the basic idea but there's a lot
of sort of subtle details involved in
how that works that I'm not super
familiar with okay so I gotta finish up
yeah so the way to actually make this
practical is let's say you have a rigged
signature for each bit so you're gonna
have to have a different signature for
each bit in your value so the pub key
for you know funky x0 well I'm gonna
have a rig signature where I prove that
it's either 0 or 1 and here I'm gonna
prove it's either a 0 or 2 here I'm
gonna prove it's either 0 or 4 and so if
I have say 32 signatures I can now prove
a 32-bit number each of those
individuals signatures only has 2 public
keys associated with it so that's now
more feasible right I can say okay well
there's a total of 32 public keys 32
signatures not the end of the world
still kind of ugly but and then there's
optimizations where since these pub keys
are all the same right the sort of zero
value for that bit we can we can squish
them together and stuff to make it a
little bit smaller so yeah so you have a
signature per bit of your output if your
values are not too big this works right
if you say okay we're gonna limit it to
32 bits so from 0 to 4 billion now you
can prove that you know each bit was
either a 0 or 1 essentially without
revealing whether it was a 0 or 1 and
then you know it's a couple kilobytes
for output so that's a little bit it
used to be 8 bytes you just sort of said
hey I've got 37 coins also these 8 bytes
are very sparse in that they're rarely
exceed 4 bytes and there so you can sort
of come back
two down and on disk so this is a little
you know scalability wise it's an issue
right you're now going from what used to
be eight bytes is now a couple kilobytes
I think they've got it down to like two
kilobytes but still that's two kilobytes
and it's it's takes a bit more CPU time
to verify right because now instead of
verifying one signature to see that the
coins are moving to the right place
you're verifying like 30 something you
know 30 plus signatures for every input
and output also the real problem is it's
not really compatible with Bitcoin this
would be a really tricky fork to
implement how do you implement this such
that the old software on the network is
okay with these transactions where you
know what they're expecting a
transaction that has a value right how
here's how many coins are being moved if
you sort of say no I'm not gonna tell
you any more old software doesn't know
how to deal with this and by default
will reject these transactions so
there's there's ways to do it that
doesn't break compatibility but they're
pretty ugly the ways to do it is to say
like one of the ways is to say okay from
now on all these transactions all output
values have to be 0 so the old software
will still work but it'll be pretty
confused and say like I see all these
values you know I see thousands of
transactions no one seems to be sending
anyone any money they saw they seemed to
be pointless and then there's this like
hidden value that's in like a different
data structure it would look something
like Segway and like cycle it was a
little bit ugly this would be real ugly
those are the trade-offs we're dealing
with here
tricky Fork yeah ok but you get this
like this is what you get when you use
confidential transactions you we got it
right we have private unlikeable amounts
where the network can verify ok let me
verify the w+ x equals y plus c that's
actually the easy part
now let me verify for every individual w
x y and z that it is within the range of
0 to sues the 2 to the third 0 to 2 2 to
30 to toaster by verifying all these
separate ring signatures for each bit of
the amount
so but you can do it right you can
verify okay input amounts equals output
amounts all these input amounts and
output amounts are normal looking
numbers that aren't too big that aren't
right up near the modulus to wrap around
and it works just kind of big and slow
we're trying to make that faster so
probably not gonna go if you're
interested in this though there's a lot
of research about this kind of thing
right now
it's a really cool like getting in a
crazy interesting math so there's bullet
proofs which was benedict at stanford he
wrote up i mean a bunch of people wrote
it but i think it was sort of his idea
or his thing working with other people
too that's more efficient range proofs i
do not know how well it works work I
sort of tried to read the paper and got
like two pages in it but just take me a
long time and then the boramy and rig
signatures sort of the more efficient
ring signatures that can compact a lot
of data so that you're not so you know
so you get it down to like two kilobytes
for these range proofs in confidential
transactions and then I may try to give
a class about this in like a week or two
minimal the idea is that when all of the
transactions in the network are like
this and they have confidential inputs
and outputs amounts the transactions can
be canceled out in an interesting way
because the amount the output amounts
are unique right they have these binding
factors they have these range proofs and
so if you're in a block so just a hint
about middle limbal the idea is if you
have a transaction and it says okay
amounts are all obscured right but a is
being consumed B is being consumed see
it's being created D is being created
right these these are amounts and then I
see later in the block there's another
transaction which spends d coins and
sends to equines I can just I don't have
to actually verify that like a plus B
equals C plus D
and the equals the kind of thing I can
just cross these out and I can sort of
verify at a block level instead of a
transaction level that the input amounts
in output amounts all matched up right
because I don't know what D is but
anyway it was on an output side and on
an input side within the same block so
anyway it's gone right it's being it's
being added to and subtracted in this
block so I can sort of do that and I can
do that over multiple blocks and I can
basically keep a tally of how many coins
are in the system and sort of cancel
things out so that actually lets you do
some really cool things where you can
skip a lot of verification at no loss of
security so that's the idea of minimal
Wimble which is really a fun paper
because it was written by Lord Voldemort
it was just sort of someone posted like
a pastebin link on IRC and like who
knows who wrote this Lord Voldemort
except it was Lord Voldemort the French
word for Lord world war so like when
they hare translated Harry Potter into
French they changed the names around I
guess and it was the French equivalent
of Lord Voldemort and so now there's a
bunch of people programming memorable
and implementing it and they all use
like Harry Potter Nate not all of them
but a lot of them use Harry Potter names
on github so it's kind of it's kind of
funny it's also really funny that like
it was sort of one of the most I would
say the most like whoa kind of paper of
2016 now and so it's just sort of
interesting indicator of the space we're
working in that like you know you've got
IBM and all these big companies and
they're working on like blockchain
research and like honestly not a ton of
awesome stuff whereas like whoa middle
limbal okay Lord Voldemort he like
really should ever so it's kind of fun
that it's like still very sort of out
there hacker he kind of system okay so
that's hopefully most people got most of
the idea it's it's a little bit fast to
sort of explain all the Petersons
commitments and range proofs and
everything in a little bit of time but I
think you got the idea and if you're
interested in it there's a lot of
current research on this and people
implementing it and there's a lot of
cool things you can do with it